Y por una vez, los pronósticos se cumplieron.
El presidente de Francia, Enmanuel Macron
no sólo venció sino que aplastó a su rival
Marine Le Pain, en la segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales francesas.
Hablamos ni más ni menos que de 16 puntos
de diferencia, aproximadamente 58% para Macron,
42% para Le Pen.
Sí, la diferencia fue más reducida que en
las anteriores presidenciales en las que también
se enfrentaron estos dos políticos y en las
que la diferencia fue de 32 puntos, pero aún
así hablamos de una enorme diferencia en
un país donde la reelección no es precisamente
algo común.
La victoria de Macron supone la primera vez
en 20 años que un presidente francés ha
conseguido un segundo mandato.
Y la primera en más de 50 años que lo ha
hecho dominando completamente la vida política
sin tener que cohabitar con un gobierno y
un Primer Ministro de un partido distinto
elegido por la Asamblea Nacional.
La primera vez en más de 50 años.
No me negaréis que se trata de todo un tanto
político.
Más aún si tenemos en cuenta que la reelección
se ha producido tras una pandemia, una crisis
y en medio de una enorme espiral inflacionista.
Y que encima la abstención ha sido enorme.
Y qué, queréis que os diga, cuando quieres
cambiar o prefieres la alternativa no te quedas
en casa.
En otras palabras, casi que podemos hablar
de un nuevo rey sol para la política francesa.
No es el líder más querido y tiene fama
de autoritario, pero tiene mando en plazo.
Y sí, lo más chocante de todo es que los
franceses no le tienen especial cariño.
En las encuestas de valoración habitualmente
se le tacha de ser arrogante, autoritario
y snob.
Seguro que fotos como está no ayudan:
Y no solo eso.
Tampoco podemos decir que su propuesta política
parezca encandilar a las masas.
En la primera vuelta, casi el 60 % de los
votantes franceses apoyaron a los candidatos
de extrema derecha o extrema izquierda.
De hecho su victoria ha venido acompañada
de una abstención de 28 puntos, la más alta
también en medio siglo en una segunda vuelta.
Está claro que Macron no levanta pasiones.
Pero entonces, ¿por qué ha arrollado Macron?
¿Hacía dónde se dirige la política francesa?
¿Qué podemos esperar en este nuevo mandato
al frente de Francia?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
1(¿POR QUÉ MACRON?)
El líder francés ha manejado Francia con
mano firme.
En 2017 llegó al poder al giro de “ni de
derechas ni de izquierdas”, sólo él mismo
para intentar dar forma a una nueva Francia.
A lo largo de su primer mandato hubo momentos
en los que su presidencia parecía cerca del
fin, sin embargo siempre se repuso.
Una y otra vez.
Ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de los chalecos
amarillos, las mayores protestas en décadas,
o incluso la crisis de la COVID-19 donde al
comienzo los franceses se encontraban entre
los más exceptivos con las vacunas.
Hoy el 78% de la población está completamente
vacunada, un porcentaje superior al de Alemania,
el Reino Unido o los Estados Unidos.
Pero sobre todo ha intentado modernizar Francia.
Y cuando hablamos de modernizar el país galo
hablamos sobre todo de su economía.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la economía
de Francia ha crecido a una media del 1% durante
los últimos 10 años.
Y si en vez de mirar el conjunto de la economía,
miramos el PIB per cápita.
Bueno creo que una imagen vale más que mil
palabras.
Atentos a este gráfico:
En dólares internacionales los franceses
llevan perdiendo riqueza desde hace más de
14 años.
E incluso si eliminamos el efecto de los tipos
de cambio y las variaciones de precio, el
resultado no es mucho mejor.
La producción de la economía francesa apenas
se incrementó un 6% en toda la década anterior
a la pandemia.
Este es un registro mucho peor que el de la
mayor parte de los países desarrollados.
Es decir, tal y como podéis ver, la economía
francesa ha estado prácticamente en coma.
Si tuviéramos que definir sus números durante
la última década, siendo generosos, podríamos
decir que son decepcionantes.
Hablamos de un déficit de más del 6% del
PIB, una deuda pública superior al 112% , un
gasto público desorbitado que supone ni más
ni menos que un 55% del PIB y un crecimiento
prácticamente nulo en los últimos años.
Es difícil encontrar alguna estadística
dónde las cosas vayan realmente bien.
De hecho se me ocurre que un buen indicador
puede ser la producción industrial, que en
los países desarrollados se encuentra en
sus máximos históricos.
Y Francia ha sido tradicionalmente un país
muy industrial.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Cómo ha evolucionado
la producción de la industria francesa?
Pues amigos, de nuevo creo que una imagen
vale más que mil palabras.
Pues bien, para solucionarlo, Macron ha hecho
esfuerzos por desregular la economía y reducir
los impuestos.
Esfuerzos que han sido muy bien acogidos por
la comunidad empresarial y que por ejemplo
han posibilitado que el desempleo se reduzca
hasta el 7%, los niveles más bajos desde
el 2008.
Entre su haber también está haber logrado
que Francia esté teniendo la recuperación
post-COVID más rápida de las grandes economías
de Europa.
De hecho, tal y como podéis ver en este gráfico
era la única gran economía que a finales
del 2021 había recuperado ya su nivel pre-pandemia.
Entre sus sus primeras medidas tras ser investido
presidente en 2017 fue abolir el impuesto
de patrimonio.
Y entre sus grandes logros se suele destacar
la reducción de 8 puntos en el impuesto de
sociedades y la reforma laboral facilitando
la contratación y el despido.
Quizás por ello no resulta extraño que según
las encuestas casi 8 de cada 10 directivos
de empresas hayan votado por el presidente
francés.
Pero en cualquier caso hablamos de cambios
tímidos.
Al menos mucho más tímidos de lo que realmente
necesita la economía gala, pero que de momento
han funcionado.
Y esa es la línea de trabajo que ahora se
ha comprometido a seguir.
Entre sus promesas está reducir los impuestos
sobre la producción para empresas y autónomos
en 7.000 millones de euros, recortar el impuesto
de sucesiones y alcanzar un déficit del 3%
del PIB para 2027.
Es decir, ajustes discretos y 5 años más
gastando a lo loco.
Tan solo desde que dio comienzo la guerra
en Ucrania el gobierno francés se ha gastado
22.000 millones de euros en compensar a los
consumidores y las empresas por las subidas
del gas, la electricidad o la gasolina.
Todo a golpe de dinero público.
Y de hecho, las estimaciones apuntan a que
las promesas de Macron lejos de contener la
hemorragia añadirán 44.000 millones de euros
anuales al déficit del gobierno francés.
Si es que cumple sus promesas, claro está.
Sea como sea lo que sí se espera es un rol
internacional mucho más agresivo.
Macron quiere lograr que París se ponga a
los mandos de Bruselas.
Sin ir más lejos en los últimos meses hemos
visto como ha querido jugar un papel muy pero
que muy relevante en la crisis de Ucrania.
Aunque no le haya salido particularmente bien.
Cómo iba a pensar el bueno de Enmanuel que
no sería capaz de hacer entrar en razón
a Vladirmir Putin.
El caso es que ahora se da por hecho que el
gobierno francés apoyará que Europa establezca
un embargo petrolero sobre Rusia.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Justo la crisis de Ucrania nos ha enseñado
una de las partes más volátiles y veletas
de este personaje.
Esta es quizás la peor cara del presidente
de Francia: el eterno oportunismo de París.
Atentos.
(LA CARA MÁS OPORTUNISTA DEL PRESIDENTE GALO)
Sobre todo y ante todo, queridos amigos, amigas,
Macron ha sido un tipo con suerte y con la
suficiente agilidad para mover sus naves de
rumbo cuándo el viento soplaba en una dirección
distinta a la suya.
El último ejemplo lo tuvimos con la invasión
rusa de Ucrania, o mejor dicho, durante los
prolegómenos de la invasión.
Tal y como os contamos en el boletín de Patreon
y también aquí en el canal en un pasado
vídeo, Macron quiso aprovechar la tensión
en la frontera ucraniana para poner distancia
con Washington, reclamar una postura europea
propia, negociar con Putin y vengarse por
la afrenta sufrida con AUKUS, cuando el gobierno
australiano canceló un contrato multimillonario
de submarinos con la industria militar francesa
para pactar con Estados Unidos y Reino Unido.
Y eso no fue lo peor, lo peor es que París
se enteró prácticamente por la prensa.
Ahí, que poco queda de la influencia de Francia.
En ese momento el presidente francés dijo
cosas como esta:
(C1: Los europeos deben dejar de ser ingenuos
[...] Tenemos que responder y demostrar que
tenemos la fuerza y la capacidad para defendernos”
Enmanuel Macron)
Así que cuando las cosas en Ucrania se pusieron
al rojo vivo Macron vio la oportunidad perfecta
para asestarle una patada al gobierno de Estados
Unidos.
Por eso, en el mismísimo Parlamento Europeo
dijo exactamente esto:
(C2: "Es bueno que los europeos y los Estados
Unidos se coordinen, pero es necesario que
los europeos lleven a cabo su propio diálogo".
- Emmanuel Macron, presidente de Francia ante
el Parlamento Europeo)
Ni postura común, ni reforzar la OTAN ni
nada por el estilo.
La Unión Europea tenía que ir por libre
para negociar con Putín.
Claro que no convenció a nadie.
Mientras París hacia un llamamiento a la
unidad europea, Varsovia, Tallín, Riga, Vilnius,
Praga, Estocolmo, Helsinki, Copenhague, Bratislava…Prácticamente
todas las capitales comenzaron a mirar a Washington
y la OTAN.
Era la mejor protección posible, la única
posible.
Y para colmo luego se produjo la invasión.
Estaba claro que la respuesta militar era
la única viable.
Y ahí la OTAN gana por goleada.
El plan de Macron se fue a hacer puñetes.
¿Y sabes qué?
Rápidamente dio un giro de 180 grados.
Un giro que, en cierta forma, también ha
protagonizado durante la campaña de la segunda
vuelta, cuándo ha hecho suyos algunas posiciones
de la izquierda: como ralentizar el incremento
de la edad de jubilación o volcarse con los
verdes.
Exactamente lo contrario de lo indica su propio
diagnóstico económico.
(N1: Macron diluye la reforma clave de las
pensiones en un intento de cortejar a la izquierda.
FT)
Evidentemente, el poder es el poder, y Francia
es Francia, tampoco vamos a culpar pero ello,
ni pedir peras al olmo.
El problema es que estas cuestiones reflejan
las grandes carencias del presidente galo:
Macron ha contribuido a mejorar Francia, pero
no ha protagonizado el cambio radical que
prometió.
Ni parece en disposición de hacerlo.
Ahora, la victoria de Macron significa continuidad
en la política económica y también en la
política exterior.
Y, eso sí, y aquí me vais a permitir mojarme
personalmente: aunque los resultados hasta
ahora han sido más bien pobres, parece claro
que era con diferencia la mejor opción.
Y no sólo hablo de Marie Le Pen.
Lo cierto es que casi que podríamos decir
que la política de Francia está a la deriva.
(POLÍTICA DE EXTREMOS)
Atentos a estas declaraciones:
C3(En cuanto la guerra ruso-ucraniana haya
terminado y se haya resuelto con un tratado
de paz, pediré la puesta en marcha de un
acercamiento estratégico entre la OTAN y
Rusia.
Es en interés de Francia y Europa, así como
de Estados Unidos", Marine Le Pen)
Una declaración que se entiende mejor cuándo
tenemos en cuenta este otro compromiso:
N3(Le Pen promete sacar a Francia del Mando
Aliado de la OTAN si gana las presidenciales:
Europa Press)
Le Pen sigue viendo a Francia como toda una
superpotencia mundial.
Una superpotencia que tiene reclamar su sitio
en el mundo.
Y para ello no ve nada mejor que mandar al
carajo a la OTAN y la Unión Europea para
impulsar políticas proteccionistas, acercarse
a Moscú y hacer malabares económicos.
Porque Le Pen prometió grandes bajadas de
impuestos, pero también grandes incrementos
del gasto.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Eso no suele ser una buena combinación.
Huele más a populismo que a otra cosa.
Como cuando dice querer luchar contra la inflación
castigando el comercio internacional y bajando
el IVA, lo que impulsaría aún más la demanda
de las familias y con ella los precios…
Ejem.
Bueno, ya sabéis que el papel lo aguanta
todo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se ha cuantificado
que las promesas de Le Pen supondrían un
déficit adicional de 105 mil millones de
dólares para alcanzar un agujero total de
266 mil millones por año.
Ya sabéis hacer grande a Francia, al menos
a la deuda de Francia.
Entre sus propuestas también encontrábamos
cosas cómo restablecer el impuesto sobre
el patrimonio, nacionalizar la red de autopistas,
bajar la edad de jubilación a 60 años o
pagar a las familias hasta 100.000 euros a
cambio de que tuvieran al menos 3 hijos.
Amigos, durante el siglo XVIII este país
le dio al mundo los conceptos de izquierda
y derecha, ahora está liderando también
una nueva transición de bandos políticos
que el analista Gideon Rachman califica como
“nacionalistas” contra los “internacionalistas”.
Entre quienes temen la globalización y quienes
la abrazan como una oportunidad.
C5(No hay más izquierda ni derecha.
La verdadera división es entre los patriotas
y los globalistas".
Marie Le Pen)
Claro que eso es limitar y simplificar mucho
el espectro político.
Sea como sea, a pesar del resultado, la extrema
derecha de Le Pen y compañía está más
fuerte que nunca.
Y de hecho estuvo por delante entre los jóvenes
y la clase trabajadora.
El nacionalismo, el euroescepticismo y el
rechazo a la inmigración cada vez gana más
adeptos.
Y por la izquierda tres cuartas partes de
lo mismo.
Que el líder del bloque de izquierdas sea
un candidato tan radical como Mélenchon tampoco
inspira mucha confianza.
La sociedad francesa parece cada vez más
dividida y polarizada.
Y si las cosas siguen yendo de mal en peor
en Francia, puede que en poco tiempo el resultado
sea muy diferente.
En la primera vuelta de estas elecciones el
histórico centro izquierda se quedó con
el 2% de los votos y por el centro derecho
no se alcanzó un raquítico 5%.
El espectro político se repartió entre el
centro de Macron y los extremos.
C6(“El mayor desafío de Macron será crear
una sensación de cohesión en un país extremadamente
fragmentado”.
Tara Varma, Consejo Europeo de Relaciones
Exteriores)
Pero al menos por ahora hay 5 años de continuidad.
Esto es precisamente por lo que la reelección
del presidente galo ha sido recibida entre
grandes vítores por prácticamente todos
los líderes internacionales, desde Biden
hasta el propio Zelensky pasando por Von der
Layen.
C7(Congratulations to @EmmanuelMacronon his
re-election.
France is our oldest ally and a key partner
in addressing global challenges.
I look forward to our continued close cooperation
— including on supporting Ukraine, defending
democracy, and countering climate change.)
Sea como sea, ahora se abre una nueva batalla,
lo que se conoce como la tercera vuelta: Macron
necesita ganar las elecciones a la Asamblea
Nacional de junio para poder gobernar a su
antojo.
Y, ¿Qué queréis que os diga?
Visto lo visto, esperemos que lo consiga.
Macron no está siendo un presidente revolucionario,
pero al menos ha logrado girar algo el oxidado
timón de la política francesa.
Sí, puede que no sea suficiente, pero algo
es algo.
Y en las alternativas no parece que haya más
que viejas recetas que recuerdan más a los
viejos mensajes populistas de América Latina
que los países más prósperos.
Claro que Francia necesita tantos cambios:
economía, pensiones, seguridad…
En cualquier caso, lo que resulta sorprendente
han sido los resultados de las elecciones
en los territorios franceses de ultramar:
han sido completamente distintos a los de
la metrópoli.
En la Francia más alejada de París, Marie
Le Pain ha tenido unos resultados particularmente
buenos, de hecho ha ganado en lugares como
Reunión, Guadalupe, la Guayana o Martinica,
entre otros.
En algunos, además, por amplia diferencia.
¿Qué ocurre en la Francia de ultramar?
¿Por qué parece tan diferente a la metrópoli?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, de todo esto
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo, aquí en
VisualPolitik, así que no olvides suscribirte
al canal si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Y ahora, turno para ti.
¿Qué piensas de los resultados de las elecciones
francesas?
¿Qué opinión tienes de Emmanuel Macron?
¿Crees que Francia logrará remontar el vuelo?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ya sabes, si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.